just click
hi everyone ken's working
uh hi everyone uh my name is fermi um i
just finished a phd at princeton
advisory mark sandri and i'm going to be
i'm starting post doc here at simons and
berkeley with
umesh bazarani and alessandra keza
i'll be talking about post-quantum
sustained arguments breaking the quantum
rewinding barrier this is a joint work
with alessandra casa nick spooner and
mark pantry
all right so uh the motivating question
for uh this work as well as a lot of my
research is uh why are quantum computers
a threat to cryptography
okay so to sort of answer this properly
i just want to recall how we prove
security in cryptography
so say you've written down a
cryptographic protocol and you want to
claim that it has some desirable
security property well how do you
formalize this
the way we do this in cryptography is a
crypto security proof breaks down into
two components
first there's a computational hardest
assumption this is something like hard
to invert a one-way function
and then you couple this with a security
reduction
and what your reduction should say is
that any efficient attack on your
protocol is going to lead to a way to
break the underlying hardness assumption
so as long as you have confidence in
your underlying hardest assumption and
you've modeled your attacks correctly
then you should have confidence that
your resulting protocol is actually
secure
all right so with this in mind
uh why are quantum computers a threat
well the short term immediate answer is
that shore's algorithm enables a quantum
computer to break a lot of the hardest
assumptions we like to use in
cryptography sort of an unfortunate
historical coincidence that uh the
problems that we've based all of the
public key crypto in use today are
exactly the problems that quantum
computers will break particularly
factoring and discrete log
okay so
the good news is that there is some hope
for post-quantum cryptography um
so post-quantum cryptography means
cryptography for classical computers or
classical machines interacting with each
other
where security holds against quantum
attacks that's what post quantum means
and so the minimum requirement for
post-quantum cryptography
is that you base your cryptosystems on
underlying hard problems that resist
quantum attacks unfortunately we have uh
candidate heart problems so various
problems on lattices isogenys and so on
so forth
uh but a common misconception is that
this is sort of the only thing you need
to look at right that you can take some
classically secure cryptosystem and then
replace your quantumly broken assumption
for one that is a quantumly secure right
like you might think that this this
fixes the problem but this is not
actually the only consideration this is
a common misconception that you just
need to fix the assumption
and what i'm getting at here the key
point is that there's another half of
the equation that you have to pay
attention to
so in a security proof you need both a
post quantum hardness assumption and a
security reduction that explicitly
handles quantum computers
so what i mean by that is if you already
proved security in the classical setting
you probably wrote down a classical
reduction
and that reduction showed that any
classical attack on the protocol leads
to a classical attack on the assumption
but now you're trying to claim security
against quantum attacks and so you need
to make sure your reduction actually
says the bottom thing which is that any
quantum attack on the protocol implies a
quantum attack on the assumption
so this is what i call a quantum
compatible reduction and it's essential
that you actually have
such a reduction to claim any post
quantum security
so many classical reductions are in fact
quantum compatible if you stare at it a
little bit you'll realize that a lot of
reductions do handle quantum computers
but phantograph in his 98 phd thesis
observed that there is a large class of
reductions in cryptography
that are not quantum compatible
and the reductions that do something
called rewinding
so if you haven't seen it before i don't
really have time to get into the details
but i will show you the underlying
mechanic of what it means to rewind
so
what does it mean to rewind well say you
have some interactive protocol and
you're trying to prove security against
say some malicious approver
so what this reduction might do is have
a regular conversation with the prover
as if it's the other party in the
interaction
write down the transcript of the
interaction
and then it's going to reset the prover
to its initial to an earlier state in
the interaction
and from that reset state it's going to
have another interaction with this
prover and then write down that
interaction
so the goal of what you do with
rewinding in the security reduction is
you use this property to extract many
transcripts from the adversary
and then together you might use these
transcripts to break some heart problem
so what goes wrong if this malicious
proverb is potentially a quantum
computer well this very first step right
the first time you interact with this
adversary the way that it computes its
classical answers might be through
measurement
and if it's doing measurements then it
might actually destroy its internal
state
and then it's unclear how you can rewind
back to an earlier point in the protocol
and get more transcripts out of this
adversary so this style of arguing
security just doesn't work it works
totally fine on classical computers
because you can just reset in an earlier
state but it doesn't work in the quantum
setting
okay so uh this has been a major problem
for over two decades now and uh there
were some prior works that were uh able
to show some limited positive results
for quantum rewinding
in particular this work of unru from
2012 showed that there is some amount of
rewinding you can do you can get a
constant number of accepting transcripts
from a quantum adversary
and this is enough for some settings but
it's insufficient for some really
important uh
results in cryptography and the one that
i'm focusing on today is this uh
primitive of succinct arguments for np
okay so uh before i go on what is a
succinct argument
it's basically one of the most
uh basic settings you have in computer
science approver is trying to convince a
verifier that something is true
in particular uh they've agreed on some
np instance in the threesat instance
and the prover has a witness and the
approver just wants to convince the
verifier that that it's a yes instance
and the sustained part of sync arguments
means that we want the total
communication to be much shorter than
actually sending the whole witness over
so we want a protocol that allows the
prover to do much better than sending
the witness to the verifier we want much
less communication and in particular we
want something like poly logarithmic in
the witness size
it's an exponential improvement over to
sending the witness
and uh the argument part just means that
the soundness condition the soundness is
only supposed to hold against efficient
cheating proverbs strategies
so it's not unconditional soundness is
you only have soundness the verifier
won't be fooled as long as the
malicious prover is efficient
so being fooled means that it acts as a
no instance that the verifier would end
up accepting
okay so a seminal result of killian from
1992 is that succinct arguments for np
exist for any np language assuming just
collision resistant hash functions which
are a relatively mild cryptographic
assumption
and if it's something you've never heard
about i just want to take a moment and
pause here like i think this is a really
like
beautiful statement but uh you can use
cryptography to solve this problem of
efficient verification that on its
surface may have like nothing to do with
crypto
um and so this is this is used
everywhere this is used in like
blockchain and
blockchain applications in practice and
also used everywhere in theory so it's a
really uh foundational statement
uh but actually it has no no quantum
analog it had no quantum analog
in particular the security of killian's
protocol was only proven for
classical malicious provers
and the root of the problem is in the
way the security proof goes
uh so as i hinted at before
the problem is in this rewinding step
that the way that you prove security is
you rewind this malicious prover many
many times and eventually extract an
empty witness from the malicious proofer
and that leads to a contradiction if
it's a no instance
and because the mp witnesses are you
know polynomial length and the messages
are really short because it's sync
protocol you have to rewind many times
to piece these messages together and get
a witness
so proving security of killian's
protocol requires polynomially many
rewinds
and that's exactly why we didn't have
post quantum security of this before
because existing techniques got stuck at
rewinding a constant number of times
okay so what we show in this work is
that killian's original protocol
with an appropriate post-quantum hash
function is in fact post-quantum secure
secure against any quantum attack
and the way we resolve this is by
addressing this quantum rewinding
question head on
we give a general purpose quantum
rewinding technique to take any quantum
adversary and extract an unbounded
number of accepting transcripts from it
and so this has many other applications
killing is the primary application uh
but naturally this rewinding technique
is everywhere and so
the side applications are that we show
that a whole bunch of other protocols
are uh just as quantum secure as they
were classical secure
so let me just sort of very very briefly
go over the
high level idea in one slide
the key observation the thing that that
differentiates this technique from prior
works is that
the way we do rewinding is by focusing
exclusively on the adversary's success
probability right at the very beginning
the adversary is assumed to have some
probability of convincing the verifier
and it has some some internal state that
allows it to do this
and what we care about actually is not
preserving we don't really care about
the internal state of the adversary
beyond its ability to convince the
verifier and so this is the one
parameter that we try to uh
keep constant throughout our protocol
throughout our rewinding
and the way we do this is by using this
useful quantum algorithm amplitude
amplification
which roughly speaking allows you to
take a quantum state s and move it to b
being in some subspace pi of quantum
states
and
at a very high level what we show is
that there is some subspace pi you can
write down that approximately
corresponds to adversaries that have a
high probability of convincing the
verifier
and then what we show is that by using
amplitude amplification if you've
disturbed the adversary's state from
querying it you can actually restore its
success probability by projecting it
back onto the subspace of good adversary
states and then you can continue uh
rewinding the adversary or continue
querying the adversary
so as a recap
this technique allows us to extract any
number of accepting transcripts that you
want and prove post-quantum security of
killing and succinct arguments
and an upcoming work with alex lombardi
and nick spooner we improve on this even
further
and as one application of our improved
rewinding
we show finally that the gmw-86 graphics
non-isomorphism protocol is your
knowledge against quantum malicious
verifiers
thought that was great um
while uh
your c setting up can we is there a
question
uh hi um
so the the subspace is it only for
efficient
uh adversary uh provers or is it
uh so the killian protocol it's only for
efficient
provers right yeah the subspace contains
all approvers that have a good
probability convincing but we show that
there's an efficient way to get into the
subspace which is what's important
so you like there there are exists there
do exist days in the subspace that
correspond to inefficient reverse okay
or like might contain a state that like
you can efficiently get two but we get
to the subspace in an efficient way
using application
so the state that we'll have in the
procedure will be we'll get to it
i see so as long as you keep projecting
you'll stay in that kind of efficient
part of that
sure yeah
actually uh wouldn't you say it's a
little more
uh analogous to uh it's it's uh you're
using something more like uh marriott
watchers and all this you know you keep
going back from
application here but it's a view that
marionette watchers can be thought of
morally as i put out a slower after
application algorithm with like one less
negligible successful ability
there's many ways to view merit watchers
but it is kind of everything in one
album